how are two brothers Fates tied together
why is Miles Morales responsible for
that shocking twist let's untangle some
of the more Twisted webs in Spider-Man
across the spider-verse Major Spoilers
ahead
one of the more mundane conflicts in
across the spider-verse is also one of
the first places where audiences might
get a bit confused when miles shows up
late to his dad's promotion party he
gets into it with both his parents and
ends up grounded the only problem with
this is that Miles doesn't live with his
parents most of the time miles lives in
a dorm at Visions during the weekdays at
least that's the case in the first
spider-verse but miles takes it pretty
seriously when his parents say he is
grounded for a month wanna get out of
here
I'm grounded even if he wasn't
Spider-Man wouldn't miles be living
without their supervision most of the
time anyway so what's the point of
grounding him the point of this sequence
is to raise the emotional Stakes between
miles and his parents in a relatable way
in this way it makes sense and succeeds
in uh grounding miles as a character who
is starting to grow into his later teen
years it sets up the Thematic Stakes of
not just this movie but the next one in
the series as well
right after his parents decide to ground
him Rio Morales observes that Miles has
a genuine connection to Gwen and lets
him go out instead so what gives why
does miles's Mom go behind his dad's
back the choice makes sense given the
movie's focus on giving Ryo Morales more
to do than she gets in the first film
while she is barely a character in into
the spider-verse this moment allows her
to make decisions and have agency apart
from Jefferson this Choice also comes
after Rio gives a touching speech about
how she spent her whole life protecting
miles from the world across the
spider-verse acknowledges that part of a
coming-of-age story is parents
recognizing that they have to start to
let go and trust their kids Ria Morales
has begun to accept this while miles is
dead might never quite get there in the
end of the movie miles finally decides
to fess up importantly he chooses to
tell his mom that he is Spider-Man
because she shows more fluency in
miles's emotions earlier in the story he
feels that he can open up to her and the
audience understands why he's more
comfortable sharing his spider secret
with his mom than his dad
introduced to the Cinematic Universe in
the end credit sequence of into the
spider-verse Miguel O'Hara appears for
real and across the spider-verse
Spider-Man 2099 is a dimension hopping
Spidey who is the de facto leader of the
group of spider people that makes sure
the spider-verse stays intact but what
exactly is his deal you know you're the
only Spider-Man who isn't funny you're
supposed to be funny between his
Spider-Man 2099 Powers claws tendency to
shift into animalistic shapes and his
menacing red eyes it's not clear whether
we are supposed to trust Miguel or fear
him it's joked that he might be a
vampire but his true nature is
intentionally kept mysterious it's clear
that the morality of Spider-Man 2099
will be a continued plot thread in the
next entry in The spider-verse Saga
the second half of across the spider
verse finds miles Gwen and the rest of
the spider people chasing the spot as he
tries to grow powerful enough to defeat
Spider-Man traveling from one universe's
main alchemax building to the next he
recreates the chemical explosion that
originally turned him into a villain in
a bid to grow to an even higher power
level
can't really get a job anywhere anymore
being like this so I've turned to a life
of crime and trying to stop him miles
gets caught in the explosion and sees a
flash of images this moment acts as the
Catalyst for the visions that Miles sees
for the rest of the movie in a couple of
instances during the last parts of
across the spider-verse miles sees
visions of the spot and some vague
glimpses of the future while we don't
know for sure what's going on there is
definitely more significance to this
event that isn't being talked about yet
something clearly happens to miles in
this moment that connects him to the
spot
there is quite a bit of exposition in
the middle of across the spider verse
many important ideas are communicated to
Miles and by extension the audience for
the first time and some of them are sure
to go over the average viewer's head the
big confusing one here is the idea of a
Canon event
there's chapters that are a part of
every spider's story every time these
events are supposed to hunt in some
shape or form to every spider person
these are can
or can they occur in the form of a
tragedy the death of the mentor figure
or lover for example these are character
defining details that have been twisted
and applied to each version of the
character throughout Decades of comics
for the Peter Parker of Earth 616 these
tragedies are the losses of Uncle Ben
and Gwen Stacy but even in a universe
where Gwen survives that universe is
Spider-Man still has their equivalent to
Gwen according to Miguel if you stop one
of these from happening your universe
will eventually fall apart miles is
willing to put that theory to the test
by trying to save his dad from his
impending death despite it being
pre-ordained as one of his Canon events
not only does it cross the spider-verse
introduce the concept of Canon events
but it also immediately complicates it
by giving miles knowledge of the future
he wants to jump back into his timeline
and stop his dad's supposedly inevitable
death but Miguel shuts him down by
trapping him when Gwen learns that
miles's Dad is supposed to die after
becoming a police captain she realizes
her own father's fate could follow the
same pattern the death of Captain Stacy
is a canonical event that happens in a
few major Peter Parker stories and for
obvious reasons also has a major impact
on Gwen Stacy's history on Earth 616
it's a Prelude to an even bigger death
Gwen's similarly the death of Miles dad
Jefferson Davis is a defining moment for
that character in insomniac's Spider-Man
video game across the spider-verse
parallels this loss and even presents
the option that it might be preventable
by using a promotion to Captain as
symbolic of a death sentence the movie
once again draws a parallel between the
stories of Gwen and Miles right before
Gwen's dad is killed it is shown that
he's promoted to Captain which mirrors
Jefferson's promotion these two Fates
are tied together in the end it seems
like Gwen has saved her dad from taking
the promotion by revealing she is
Spider-Woman this suggests that perhaps
miles can save his father by telling him
the truth
across the spiderverse expands upon and
solidifies the idea that there is only
meant to be one spider person per
Universe my name is Miles Morales I'm
Brooklyn's one and only Spider-Man this
makes Miles Morales an anomaly by
definition which puts him between a rock
and a hard place by the end of the movie
you see miles is a second Spider-Man in
a world that was only supposed to have
won the Peter Parker that died in the
beginning of into the spider-verse but
by getting bitten by a radioactive
spider From Another Dimension Earth 42
Miles Morales apparently became an
individual who isn't supposed to exist
in the makeup of the spider-verse what
this movie establishes is that every
Universe has its own spider person and
they have a predetermined Destiny this
universe is Miles Morales was never part
of the spider versus plan Gwen knows
more than she lets on about this for the
entire movie and retroactively you see
why she has been so distant and so
caring at the same time she knows miles
wouldn't have been able to just accept
the news about his dad without trying to
intervene making the inevitable reveal
of her knowledge even more heartbreaking
miles was never meant to be Spider-Man
and not only did his presence get Peter
Parker killed it created a universe
where there is no Spider-Man across the
spider-verse only begins to scratch the
surface of what that world could look
like
the final twist in across the spider
verse is that in the dimension that
Miles indirectly robbed of a Spider-Man
Miles turns into something else first
time viewers will assume that the
menacing Aaron is still the prowler but
they will be proven wrong when the real
Prowler pops into the scene that's right
this version of Miles Morales turned
into a super villain this twist ending
sets up miles as the prowler to be the
big bad or at least one of them in
beyond the spider-verse it's not
explained whether the miles on Earth 42
ends up as the prowler because our miles
took his place as Spider-Man or because
the lack of a Spider-Man led him down
this path either way the miles we know
has created a super villain in a world
without a Spider-Man to stop him and now
it will be his responsibility to
literally fight with himself finally
blurring the line between miles's
internal conflicts and external threats
in one of the final scenes of the movie
once it's finally revealed where Miles
has teleported to we see a mural painted
in memory of Jefferson Davis at the same
time we already know that Uncle Aaron is
alive in this universe these two things
could be connected and we may later
learn that Jefferson's death is
connected with the reasons that Aaron is
still alive in the first spider-verse
Aaron dies after being revealed as the
prowler but that's not always How The
Story Goes Down in the Insomniac
Spider-Man game for example Jefferson
dies while Aaron is still alive in fact
all signs point to the idea that miles's
Dad needs to die for the character to
move along his natural Arc since miles
is an anomaly and across the
spider-verse this might even suggest
that his Dad was supposed to die earlier
but miles altered the path which ended
up leading to his uncle's death instead
many of these details won't be cleared
up until the sequel one thing is for
sure though this alternate universe
where one Davis brother dies instead of
the other will be important in beyond
the spider-verse
[Music]